So, you can see how this diagram that I drew earlier works. The circle
representing the natural numbers is within the circle representing the whole
numbers, showing that the natural numbers are all included in the whole numbers.
If we pick any number, we can point to which category or categories it fits into
by pointing somewhere on this diagram. For example, if I pick 18, then 18 is a
natural number. So we can point here. But since that circle is inside of the
whole number circle, we know that 18 is also a whole number. If we pick zero
however, We can only point to the whole number circle, not the natural number
circle since zero is whole, but not natural And if I pick a number like 16.5,
well, that is not in either of these categories. So we would need to point
outside of both of these circles. So you can see that we're building up this
sort of world of numbers. And we're going to keep adding more to it. Next, we're
going to talk about integers, which, if we represent them in our world of
numbers here, would be drawn as a circle around the whole numbers like this.
Even though I haven't told you anything about integers yet. Can you tell me just
by looking at this diagram, which of the following statements are true?